so I'm currently a college student um I
just graduated with my undergraduate
degree um and I'm now working towards uh
an MBA and I'll graduate here um in
about a year from now so this upcoming
December um and I was just wondering you
know if I should continue to you know
rent in this area or move back home with
my parents uh who live in New Jersey why
would you move the rent here is uh very
expensive the nice thing is I I I spend
currently 2,000 a month in rent but I do
live with my brother who's graduated
he's a full-time job part of growing UPS
not living in Mama's basement you're a
grown man with an NBA making 90 grand
you don't need to live in your mother's
basement and that's just part of life I
mean and I mean in New York City 2000
isn't bad dude